my name is Etienne Donna my name is
Timothy Verde and we're going to present
a workshop the title is an end-to-end
machine learning project so the idea is
to walk people through all the classic
steps in a machine learning project and
not just a training part but also the
data wronging part or the deployment of
the model it's called end to end machine
learning project the idea is not just to
talk about the small part that is about
training that is actually usually a few
lines of code it's really not so big but
also speak about what comes before what
comes after so before it would be in
terms of that handling even better
storing and after in terms of
deployments this type of things and also
give some technical solution even for
training for example what what can you
do if you want to train on the cloud and
not on your machine and so we'll provide
one solution for that and and and what
can you do if you want to deploy your
machine learning model let's say on the
device so we won't explain that in
detail but at least we give you an idea
of what to do in order to to do that
that's really the ready to see all the
components of the national learning
project and actually alright so actually
that that's a part we're going to talk
about by the way is it it's big enough
maybe I put 150 although it's small
rooms that's good is that big enough
yeah so yeah talking about it that I
rounding part this is the parts are to
out to extract the data to clean the
data to augment the data how to store
the data then there's of Fernet that
understanding part that's usually when
you start playing with the data plotting
extra grams things like that to get a
feel of where this data is which is very
useful to avoid some some mistakes
sometimes there's some crazy thing in
the data and we can spot
it with this sort of simple analysis
then we talked about the modeling
okay the classic machine learning part
won't spend too much time on that
because as many in many workshops that
are exclusively about this part
including so many new network workshop
for example but still we'll talk about
how to do that in the cloud for example
and then how to use the model has been
created and how to deploy it for the
application that's you had in mind okay
so data wrangling so so this probably
often the longest part by the way so it
involved importing the data claiming
extending it so for example importing so
for that is very simple for an import
okay so you can import import
spreadsheets and actually that's it
alright that with the way to go
by the way import you can also import
some database format with import as well
so that's really the main tool this is
one tool that is called semantic import
there is more reason by import although
it's already maybe three years old now
and the idea of this function is also to
understand the data that is imported for
example in the same spreadsheet but this
time it understood that date was a date
and that city were the city and sales
was just a numeric number and and it
interpreted the date as a date object
this is a date object and it interpreted
cities as as entities okay and and this
can be useful too for example from date
you can extract extra features you can
extract what is a Sunday or not which
might be useful a useful feature or old
city you can extract later the
population which may be useful to to do
the prediction tasks that you want by
the way one thing that
no I guess I will talk it talk about it
after okay okay so that's one way to get
data you really easiest spreadsheet
pretty easy to get the data but
sometimes you might want to have some
more off-road way try scraping from the
web it's pretty classic that you have
data is on top website on some somewhat
structured way and you want to extract
this and this is a very hockey world so
so we won't go into into a full example
but but just to give you a rough idea of
usually how it goes it goes into
downloading the URL locally first okay
and that's function called URL download
URL don't let that mean that there's
that synchronously so that's that's or
to function then once you have
downloaded URL you can import them
offline and and so you can import eiper
links by the way which is useful if you
want to navigate in the website to
figure out other page to to other URL to
import so that's how you you can create
your little bots that explore the web
and and then the best thing I believe is
to import that as an XML object because
it still contains all the information
about about the page and scrape the data
from XML object and for that typically
two techniques is to use position and
part like let's say I wanna I want to
extract all the element triggered
directly to the example or maybe yeah
easier than speaking about it okay so
let's see let's see
so here's an example problem that we we
have just to go to a web page in the
Wolfram website okay so this page
and the idea is okay we want to extract
all the titles of this page okay all all
these things and and how can we do that
so the first thing as I was saying is -
okay here's our URL with the URL adder
which can be nice because you can just
click and it goes in the URL and so so
okay I mean okay let's for that case it
doesn't matter to import hyperlinks but
just I wanted to show you how to import
the hyperlinks in the right file or URL
it is a URL when it's going on okay for
some reason import doesn't work if it's
an URL that's weird but okay that's all
the links for example in this in this
page so the problem at hand it's not
it's not useful but to show that
if I remove the head yeah I mean I think
he'd go back to the stringer yeah yeah
it's not normal it should work with you
al that's weird that's weird that's a
bug and okay so now okay let's extract
let's extract this these titles so we're
going to download the URL into a file
okay so actually I could I could show
what the what the file is yes okay
that's that's the file and and then
we're going to import it as an XML
object and if you look underneath so XML
object is like this huge huge expression
okay that represents the the website and
you might say well that's crazy we'll
never manage to scrape anything from
that it's too complicated and it's
partially true because sometimes it's
pretty complicated so it's a bit of a
black art but but let's say we have okay
Wolfram language reference that's that's
the first one let's say which one is
okay what and and we can just do
position in this expression and say okay
what foreign language represent is there
then I can say oh where is Wolfram
language home page and I can look and
that's what saying is very hockey and I
say oh look there's only these the
change is from a fall to a two and and
then I say oh let's let's get something
to a second line and then I noticed oh
there's a two and six it's only change
and then I figure out that oh it's
actually agreed and I just need to put a
wrench here and put that and get over
all the all the titles okay that's very
happy way but in practice it's useful
because website are always structured
and there's always a structure and you
find the structure and you can describe
things and you know it's it's a pretty
convenient so it's another way which is
using pattern matching and this would be
kind of let's take this position okay I
start from that bad position so this
should should
grab the title and then we you know go
back in the tree so I guess something
like this and probably if you match
everything in the XML object that has
this this pattern you will grab the
title but of course you need to remove
some yes specific things that are
specific to this title so of course you
have to remove this maybe remove the
item with maybe remove the link and so
on and then you do cases and so we see
here cases I've removed that put a bit
of blank to some places and I also put a
something where where the title is an
output the title and and here you go
this actually is actually pretty pretty
robust this one so that's another case
on how you can scrape things yeah
beautiful I don't know what it is is it
a tool software to do this
it's a patent Larry okay no I don't know
I mean I always used position on cases I
mean I'm pretty used to the language so
it's pretty fast but yeah I mean I does
not matter but and matching like that
because this pattern matching thing is
pretty powerful and I think this is
something that long way is that what my
voice is pretty strong at yeah yeah
interesting yeah I didn't look at it
Thanks
okay so so let's go to deeper on that I
was saying it's a bit of a black hat but
it's very useful so another part is
about cleaning the data about
interpreting it but including some extra
features so here you can use all the
classic data manipulation function of a
language including let's remove by
example select replace things like that
interpreter very useful to interpret for
example if you know it's date you can
use interpreter date to then interpret a
date object and extract features that's
what I was talking about and you can
interpret things as entities let's say
we have cities interpreted cities and
then use entity value to extract some
features that's what we do in this
example so here the idea is to import
but not with semantic import okay there
will be cheating in that case imported
sheets should in beginning and and the
goal is to add the population of each
city the data set okay so maybe we could
work together so this is importing the
data here I just removed the names of
all the columns okay it's easier to to
endo and in order to be fast in that
case I'm just grabbing all the cities so
here I select the second column delete
duplicate so I have all the cities yeah
yes exactly
directly in section yeah so I hope that
you can yeah you have these small things
right to open okay otherwise if you
don't have this this kind of a things
you can go on the cell and double click
okay it's true yeah we close everything
I hope no one is stuck with something oh
okay so here to be fast so in that case
there's not many cities so actually we
could do it by hand and look on
Wikipedia or something but
Medicaid's you have many more things and
and for that you can use interpreter
city okay and this will interpret and
return and it is and then from this
entity you can use entity value or
actually or shorter things like that I
can just say open bracket population
close bracket will work as well to grab
the populations okay and then I do
association thread because I will do a
kind of a replace but I will do it
association and it's a bit faster and
and then I'm going to do use this this
this session so I have to replace all
the cities by they're not exactly
replace but to happened I mean at least
to get all the column of population okay
with lookup where it says accession and
this is the column in question and I do
quantity magnitude just to remove the
quantity so here I should have a list of
population and then I just happened this
column in the eggs in data set and by
just using happen by just doing a map
thread so each element I will open the
corresponding population sort of zip
type thing and I'll just that I said to
visualize again and you see we added the
population of a city and and by the way
this is a really yeah this is really
strong parts of all the Wolfram language
this since you have access to this data
I think that that's a huge added value
for data science application I mean when
I did some project in the resonance
often use that to add some some extra
features and threads yeah very useful
okay tamati will talk you about that a
storage yes
right so once you have done it was just
one thing if you have questions don't
hesitate to to speak out okay let's meet
here
I guess if you want to import it many
times for example for example sometimes
they have they have a mean baby slow to
download it each time you want to import
and also you can let as as a synchronous
task in the background you can just have
something that download everything
overnight and then you can work on
importing the correct way and so on
although if you always do XML object I
guess it's fine but my sometime try to
import in another way so yeah and also
as your like this is it's a black heart
and you are like trying trying things
and methods to get away with what you
want you you will you will have it
locally in order to play with it which
is something otherwise you relapse it's
all the XML object in a file but it's
always nice to store that and okay so so
next is how do you it's probably about
how do you build on and scale I'm sure
like started this process of getting
some data and and and how do you how do
you link that how do you use this rich
feature that of course comes from the
Wolfram Alpha and knowledge if you have
entities but in your very specific field
you might want to do that for you and
and be able to link many data set
together so at this point you don't want
to you know do all this work to two
other data sets play with this and then
put it in a random place and a new hard
disk and in two weeks after well maybe
maybe a bit longer but you say oh maybe
there was a connection between the work
I did there and you go back to your
notebook and it's it's a big mess
because it was like the dark hard part
so so on so once you get to this point
of having this clean that you might want
to store it's in in an appropriate way
in
and scallop with with all the data you
get and and this part is also some
things that will probably not evaluate
on onion on your laptop because this is
work in progress and this is to give you
a taste of what's coming and what we're
working on so yes these need 11.3 right
so yeah mongolic is a solution we use
internally - right so - our data set
yeah yes this is not supposed to work
this part is not situate one month on is
where but it's to give you its give you
an idea of how this will work and and
what's going on behind all this so what
you want to do is on C you have those
that is to organize them into database
in a way that you can actually query
link so all those those elements and and
generate new data set by actually like
just blabbing the information you need
so so for that we have been we are
people are working on this Mongolian
connection in order to enable you to do
that with with a MongoDB system which
lets you query metadata from from any
type of data set you you want to store
so once you have open a connection you
can just link to a database that I just
said with with with an example and and
and the way it's organized is you have
collections which are so one collection
is is something like what HM just
gathered with with a city is a video
it's it's a data set with documents in
the MongoDB language that is one element
with all the properties and in the field
you are interested in and so for
instance here we have a we have
this titanic collection which is which i
can like get in touch with this is all
stored on the cloud so this is this is
not local in the computers that what you
need the clients in the collection and
and and and this is the Titanic data
sets that I just knew that that was just
moved there by by me again
and once you have that you can just
create new data sets on the fly sing oh
I want those elements from the
information I had I want to link I want
to link that asset and generates the
data set for my new cripples this is
what we like an example yeah so if you
have a collection for instance this will
actually aggregate the element based on
on filtering and and put in the
organization you want so for instance
here we're gonna we're going to group so
what the Titanic collection is is a list
of Accenture the class they were
traveling and with survive don't know
their age and things like that so you
can say oh I want to to pick in these
collections information of of all those
passenger I want to group them by by sex
and and the class aware they were
traveling and I want to actually count
the number of passes passenger and our
age I and so this link allows you to
actually talk to the MongoDB system and
generates the data set you interested in
from the information you already stored
and and you can of course add a new
passenger information to you to your
data set because you you went on with
some some other scrapping data mangly
and and so so that's the ID that once
you have those data at hand you might
want to store them in an organized
manner and we are working in order to
develop the tools and the link to do
that very efficiently on
modern technologies okay by the way if
you have if you're interested in this
[ __ ] link which is really useful when
you start to have a lot of data it is
just a one-shot project with smooth data
sets
who cares but but if that I said as I
was saying that you're going to use
again later and you know you spend some
effort doing it may be worth to put it
in a nice database that is nicely
curable and so on and if you have more
question about that Megan is about that
I manager in a net weight team so you
know she can tell you more about it and
explain how it works and yeah okay so
let's go to that understanding parts
okay so now that ty is in a nice
database actually I'm not going to use
from database but but whatever let's
imagine it is and and now what we want
its to have a first feel about the data
in order to avoid some bad mistakes that
we can do you know like like something
for example we might not see that a
viable meant missing you know like click
classically missing my been an you know
that I said some time is something else
let's say we don't see that we miss that
sorry then we might train and then maybe
we'll get super good result because
because or maybe let's say the missing
is an output and get super Carrizo
because always predicts missing you know
like this sort of thing there's a huge
variety of trouble we can run in and and
this helps to avoid these these problems
so so let's import to dataset so this is
about the right set of football soccer
players to American football if you're
not American and in matches is at least
thing that I scraped from from a website
to do prediction on the World Cup three
years ago there's a blog post about that
you can you can have a look which is by
the way an example of an end-to-end
machine learning project from scraping
the data to Indian using them all all to
do prediction against you know betting
odds to see if we can make money with
with this so it's
really you can have a look at that so so
I don't know did that I said and it's by
the way it's pretty classic to also have
that I said are separated in in datasets
and actually one part is also how to
merge that I said into a final better is
ready for training which I won't show
here but that's also ok so of course
let's look at the length of the players
that I said ok as almost 80,000 players
that's the features I just got you know
all values and duplicate maybe I should
have looked what it is so this is
actually an association players so you
know you're some cheese with the bigger
station so I won't show everything but
it's kind of an index of the players and
then for each of them you have another
association okay that is just an
accession of features so you have the
name of the player is birthdate is
position number of international
selection yeah things like that and it's
actually highly varying the number of
data that we have for player so ok
that's typically what we want to do so
ok this is like a subset data set and we
can see some other subsets okay that's
the kind of a tiny it's one don't have
many features or this one or more this
this guy we also have the weight and
height and the height to say that one
okay we can do the same for the match so
okay so it's the same thing right and
you have some features for each match
and such as a competition the venue the
attendance the dates and so on and so on
okay that's that's that's that is it one
important thing would be to look at
missing data so here I use at least a
data set language so I transform this
data set into a data set with a big deal
okay into the symbol data set and and
then I do that you know to transpose it
that's something that that is really
convenient with with the assets and then
I can use syntax
to say take all the columns and count
the number of missing and divide by the
player and then sort by this thing and
here we go
so here it would give the fraction of
missing features for each of missing
values for each feature so apparently we
have the name of all players basically
they always add number of selection
birds we only have 25% of player that we
know the birthdate only 20% we know that
position okay so that's something good
to our 12 in mind by the way you can
also do that without using a data set
just with classic Wolfram language
function if you're more used to it like
in that case it's much nicer syntax but
but I know even myself I'm more used to
use classic xpressions dealing with
associations so so I often don't use it
yeah transposes is let's say actually
sorry that's going data set he's doing
that as sets okay yeah for example this
example okay let me put bigger okay so
here is that a set and you see that you
have the column three columns ABC I will
transpo it with three row SBC okay it
transformed from the columns to row so
so in that case that's why these were
columns and now they are row name
selection birthdate and so on okay so we
can do the same for the match the
matches and we see a K here there's no
me seeing and it starts to be like the
manager is not there always if I go down
oops
chef click that one shouldn't have click
that one
I think we removed this thing your next
version but sometimes problems with this
bar anyway you can navigate with this
one's safer this is a front-end thing
it's like how to display that which when
this version doesn't like it okay it's a
front-end thing so I think I don't know
what your machine how to stop that
okay I can start telling you okay okay
okay oops
okay I can tell you a bit about what we
do just after it will be to look at the
distribution of features so if it's a
numerical feature okay if it's a bunch
of numbers you might want to look at the
histogram okay if it's categorical
features like let's say the position of
the player goalkeeper defender and so on
you might want to look at a bar chart or
pie chart or something like that that
this different visualization to have an
idea for example you might want to put
mistakes like you look at the
distribution of weight in player and
suddenly you see a big Pike at 2 tons
and obviously you know you know that's
wrong right there's something wrong with
the data and this happens you know did I
get manipulated a lot and and there's
some arrows and that's been to the role
you know the scientist is what this
human knowledge of ok this is the height
of someone people cannot be 4 meters
that must be wrong and I remove that and
that's that this is the idea of doing
all this but ok let's continue like this
and so for example here I just do the
Instagram for all the numerical values I
also use data sets and tax you don't
have to so here if I click it's quite
nice because it's it's a cyclic
selection I will see the Instagram so
this is a number of selection for each
player
everything says right here although
Instagram doesn't seem to be permission
to approach range or to be sure to see
everything that ki didn't do it but
actually that's been dangerous I should
have done that I should own that ok
there's no hi it's everything seems
right here
wait everything seems right ok I can do
the same on the other matches I will
look at the attendance so what and
thence ok if I click there seems ok
school 1 so that's interesting like most
most of the match the team want is a
number of goal that a team once called
is about yeah one or two goals something
like that and and
this should be about the same and this
is just a cattle call value a
categorical viable or nominal viable
this would show the continent in which
the match took place so apparently most
of them I in Europe Asia and Africa okay
that's very classic open language use a
warm language and and very useful this
is okay some other this is a bit more
advanced thing is in this case we have a
data set where you have many example
that are ordered in time okay
and one very important thing is to see
the evolution of some variable in time
first of all here just a random one okay
it's interesting mean number of goals
per match for each year and we can see
that in the past there were four goals
per match but nowadays maybe 2.5 goal
per match and that's important to
realize that the data is not the same in
the past but it is you know a different
time different period it's at the same
data it's important to know bit when you
will test because if you just randomly
and what you want is to predict what's
gonna happen in the future so if you
just shuffle every every match and then
test on that it would be a different
artistic that if you just construct a
test set that is at the end and a
training set is a beginning which is
really the setting you want you want to
train on the past and pick the future so
that's that's an important to realize
but if you see it everything is flat
that date doesn't matter
then all right let's shuffle let's do
training set tested split that I random
so in that case there is an evolution
okay that's another fun thing that's oh
yeah that's allow you to do some sort of
baseline this this give you the
percentage of match that I've been
warned when the team was at home when
the team was away and when the team was
in a neutral location and you can see
that when team were at home it's already
50% like one match out of two at home
are one that's that's a really good
baseline you can always predict that the
home team wins except sometimes there's
no home team because it's neutral but
you know if your model get there's less
than 50% of accuracy you might say oh
that there's a problem as a problem at
one night baseline was better so yeah
this sort of nice bedliner are very very
useful okay now let's go to the
alternates sport in here 14 on this one
okay
okay let's accelerate a little bit then
modeling parts but let's go because I'm
a workshop about that so we won't talk
too much yeah I'm importing that I said
that is kind of a gathering of a player
and the match but the gathering is a bit
tricky so so I just give it as ease and
because I construct extra features it
has a low ratings of each each team so
you have 30,000 example and I'm going to
cut it there so they are sorted by date
so I'm really going to cut it 25,000 and
then the last 5,000 to test okay
other training in a test set and and was
classify and predict very easy just
classify okay so there we go
I'll run classify and should start
training this is a bit of proposed I
saying then you should see a training
panel that we'll talk more about by the
way in in my talks oh that's that's
weird there's a burger what's happening
things that cut maybe because in
presentation mode whoa Wow okay yeah it
always works for me always at this time
okay that's interesting that's really
yeah yeah let's let's restart or even
just the kernel yeah
that's really wounded
okay any case that's not the most I mean
I said the goal of this talk to talk
about by the training so we're going to
go pretty fast on that again
did I just remove the I remove the thing
after classifying predict Oh No okay
this is kind of working now so you can
see this training progress panel we can
see a learning curve you can stop at any
moment
okay let let me just actually go back in
time because I removed the next uh okay
but anyway it's strained and then you
can use classic your measurements to
measure how good the thing is on the
test set so apparently because 656
percent of much right in that in that in
that cases and you can look think that
see the confusion matrix that are useful
to debug your your model and also the
bugs that has head by the way
because then you can see oh that's
really weird that this thing is
misclassified as this thing so let's
look at it and then you realize oh there
was something wrong with the training
set does mean badly tagged so so
analyzing the model sometimes you
discover problems in the in the training
set okay so that's what it's for
pacified and today we'll talk about a
train yeah locally and on the cloudy
yeah an important part so back to the
future as you may see that train there
we go so so so let's let's let's move on
the simplest example possible just to
focus on on how it works right so sine
function little bit of noise Network to
predict that okay so very very simple
network not not what we are interested
in this case and and locally is just Oh
train these network nets on the train
sets with validation sets and four or
five second so let's go and here you can
see that the training goes on for five
seconds and we got to train Nets okay
and we can show what it looks like on
the test sets
and that's things work
precision also things like that but I
want to what I want to give you an idea
of is how it is if you want to do this
on a powerful machine and remotely and
what we are preparing in terms of tool
to do that so we're going to an example
of remote training on on on on on
occlude using the cloud computing of
Amazon Web service known as elastic
cloud compute ok so in order to do so
you should prepare your data to be
transferred to the to the remote
computer so this is just like saving M
file and in the net the pre-trained nets
on on files
yeah no problem
case I know we have been met
I think it's so I I put everything in
this training folder here you can see
that you have the network you have the
train set and the validation said that I
want to move to the Machine and I'm
gonna prepare a scrip for training which
is I want in this creep - I want in the
script to actually point to the file
where there would be in the in the
remote machine so just like settings a
file pass based on the directory
position on the notebook position and
then I just important it import the
training that our import the value and
just run net train but this is a script
that's going to run on the remote
machine right so an interesting thing is
is I want to train on the GPU of the
machine that's what makes sense in this
case and I will checkpoints that is
because the machine might have some some
issue I want to save at a given interval
is the value of the network not to lose
everything and then I'm gonna export the
final network that's an important point
as fine a final that WR net okay so this
is our script and I'm gonna put the
scripts in the training directory
because I need the script on the remote
machine - and okay this is just a toy
data but you might want to actually
compress your compress where it's your
your data to move it to the to the
remote computer okay so now let's move
to the to the Amazon console to give you
a flavor of so you need you need an
Accounts whatever cloud you like
okay and no you can start a machine in
order to start a machine you will need a
machine configuration which in Amazon is
a machine image so if you have for
instance started a machine previously
installed Mathematica you can save the
configuration and logic machine from
that so that's what we have here let's
take this guy and launch a machine with
this configuration we've got we want to
GPU let's take this this one and sorry
let's take this GPU and move on so as
you can see you have you have like
plenty of configuration details that
we're gonna skip you can type your
machine saying that for instance I'm the
owner of the machine and and that's it
and now we launch a machine and it's
going to say oh you need in order to to
discuss with the machine you need to
authenticate through SSH keeper so
either you already have created one
either you created one now so let's
let's choose an existing one and I have
my key here and I have to say that I do
have my Chi on my local computer and
let's launch an instance so this will
launch the machine and make sure it's
it's ready for so here we go it's
pending and the machine is going to warm
up now here
I'm jittery
just to know where I where I'm working
at wicked like okay no I'm on the
desktop so this this should work
yes so now I have my so I just like I
just like make an archive and tar
everything in the single file because
you don't want to move like many many
files around okay so have the single
fight with all the training data in
information to transfer to the machine
and know that we have launched the
machine we will connect we will connect
to the Machine and and start the remote
training so first things that since this
is the first time I connect to this
machine I have to like acknowledges as a
known host so if I move back to the
console yes this machine I just want to
connect to it and amazonian saying oh if
you have my key you can just use these
commands here okay so this should work
let's let's try this just okay they have
default username and for it's a it's a
Linux machine so the default will be
good to hear
that's the top let's move here and let's
do it
okay so here here we are we're actually
talking to the Machine annalise.m that
was started like this and and we can and
and know that it's in the known host I
don't need to turn me on anymore and I
can just pass the cannot so first thing
I want to move my training data to to
the to the to the machine so just have
to give the actual machine address right
this is the machine address that was
sent back by Amazon and I want to move
things there right
I assume it's done see so yes training
that it's it's there then what I want to
do we won't say like oh and but like get
get the thing out of the archive right
sorry oh yeah right I hate this
it's yeah okay I need to okay so so so
so so so if I had do things properly and
change the hose this would like
uncompress York Ivan gets everything
settle and then next time is to actually
run my script okay and so on
once I've run my script it's exactly
like running something locally but it
happens on the other machine right and
and and then what I have to do is just
to move back
the final net configuration on the
machine which has been like rent on this
instance and and that's it right
so what we are actually doing what we
are actually that's
yes sir so this way of doing is a
current way you can do right now but
what we are doing is trying to develop
tools to make that easier the first step
is a AWS link that imitators going to
mention and talk about and in a future
step would be to think directly in the
Train where you can have some data and
say upload this to ec2 and you have some
sort of easy to object okay and you can
put that in a train and it would
directly train on on Amazon machine so
okay we make that even easier but we
need to show the true way to do it
right now okay so we want yes that's
part of what we are what we are like
doing what about doing currently
developing so so just to give you a view
of what it might look like soon if you
you just need to initiate the connection
and then you can use your client to
lists the the running instance so here I
see that I have this running instance
that I own on Amazon directly from from
from Mathematica I can just launch an
instance with my default value like like
this this is like I just launched an
instance with my default value if I look
inside I will get the new instance I
launched which has different values than
the one I can tag this new instance
saying that I'm the owner which is like
already working so I look at the tag on
the instance and I can eventually
terminate all those instance that's
directly there
rights and of course that you have you
have stuff like in which you can beat
for instances in order to get cheaper
price but you can get kicked out of the
machine and this is something for which
you might say oh I want the prices of of
those of this type of instance for the
last one day and and you just get those
pricey straight away from from from the
link here you can say oh so I'm gonna be
like 0.4 dollar because it's enough for
the time I want to
I need a stay there so that's what the
AWS link and the near future is about
all right cool so let's talk about use
it in the payment deployment and I think
for the training I want to stress that
again it's really three stage right now
you have to do everything with Amazon on
the website common lines then eleven
point three you can already use AWS link
and then maybe twelve I don't know
directly with with net rain and okay now
you have something trained and how do
you use it how do you deploy it so so
the simplest thing is to use locally and
from any application and you might not
want to deploy in a cloud or whatever
just use locally and so for that export
your model we created a language in
eleven point two I think that is called
move from machine learning formats W MLF
where you can store cash if your
function title function also in your
networks everything that is machine
learning related you can store it in
this format so just with exports so now
the classifier is exported and and we
can import it with import and use it
later that's how you store it on the
cloud like any other Wolfram language
code you can create form function or an
API function form function requires more
website for humans to enter things by
hand and API create something that the
machine can connect and give the inputs
in order to run a program and get output
so so I will do that very very quickly
let's say here we grab the oh but I
I quit okay then let's just talk about
it yeah we just grabbed the type from
classified information and I will
replace this type because API need to
know the type of the argument
okay so numeric or in my case it will be
number non-mineral to be straying and I
can just do a form function test the
pump function deploy it with cloud
deploy and same thing for the API
function and okay so that'sthat's really
like this is really straightforward to
deploy guide on the on the cloud and now
there's also a way to deploy on specific
device only from your networks so I let
Timothy speak about that thank you this
is - this is to show you what we're the
world from language neural network
framework is in the world of the neural
network system so so we are here and you
can currently as you can currently
export to to MX nets which is what we
use in the backend to actually run the
calculation so you can have the mix net
code which comes in to two files a JSON
files and the param file and and you can
and then you're in the AMEX net world so
anything a mix net can do you can
actually do it and so you have many
exporters which might work with several
other classic lower level language and
and from a mix Nets
the two very interesting thing to keep
in mind is that so it's actually this Oh
an annex language that is meant to be a
way to actually move from one language
to the other and which we also plan to
link and and this and if you want just
to deploy what you need is to compile
actually to do a specific architecture
and and there is already from egg mix
now this this pass from these n nvm that
is a graphic presentation of your
program TVM which is getting an
intermediate representation from which
you can compile to the whatever
architecture and
compiler you want so could i for for
which is very classic for GPU but
classic computer raspberry P Raspberry
Pi everything is going to be integrated
this is already there since we have the
importer/exporter to MX net then you can
just compiled form MX net to whatever
you want yeah okay I think that's that's
it thanks for the tank maybe just do
some question I don't think we looked at
many others because everybody very use
WS also we expect I mean we hope that
AWS will soon have the volta cards which
are blazingly fast to train your
networks so they know they will do it at
some point and say when and I don't
think there were much competition
against that